in response to james comey testimony
last week President Donald Trump now
says he is 100% willing to testify under
oath he is explicitly accusing the
former FBI director whom he fired of
just making up a ton of what he said in
front of that Senate panel on Thursday
morning let's go to Donald Trump at a
Rose Garden press conference at the
White House where get back to James
commis testimony he suggested he didn't
tell the truth and everything he said he
did say under oath that you told him to
let the Flynn you said you hoped the
Flint investigation you could like I
didn't say that so he lied about that
well I didn't say that
I mean I will tell you I didn't say that
and and did he ask you to pledge and
there'd be nothing wrong if I did say it
according to everybody that I've read
today but I did not say that and did he
ask for a pledge of loyalty from you as
an or thing he said no he did not so he
said those things under oath would you
be willing to speak under oath to give
your version of 100 percent
I didn't say under oath I hardly know
the man I'm not going to say I want you
to pledge allegiance who would do that
who would ask a man to pledge allegiance
under oath I mean think of it I hardly
know the men it doesn't make sense no I
didn't say that and I didn't say the
other so if Robert Muller wanted to
speak with you about that I would be
glad to tell them exactly what I just
said you'd you and you seem to be
hinting that there are recordings of
those converse I'm not hinting anything
I'll tell you about it over a very short
period of time
yeah more on that later we have to apply
Occam's razor here right do you believe
the guy who lies all the time
which would also sort of imply by
definition that James Comey a well-liked
and highly respected public servant of
decades of decades a career made up not
only his assertions but created fake
memos to spread the lies as well or do
you just believe that Trump is lying
which he has done before we really need
to apply Occam's razor here yeah of
course commis judgment has been called
into question but not so much the
veracity of his claims whereas Donald
Trump we know him to be a pathological
liar constantly and the great thing here
is that
Trump is picking and choosing when Comey
can be trusted and when he isn't which
is 100% Donald Trump's MO if you agree
with him you're the best if you disagree
you're absolutely the worst fake news
whatever in James commis case he's sort
of both because Donald Trump also said
at the White House Rose Garden quote
yesterday showed no collusion no
obstruction but we were very very happy
and frankly James Comey confirmed a lot
of what I said and some of the things
that he said just weren't true so we can
trust James commis memo and testimony
that he told Trump you're not personally
under investigation right now totally
trustworthy James Comey is on that issue
but the notes that Comey made right
after that same meeting now we can't
trust those notes about the loyalty
pledge we can't trust those notes about
the black cloud over my head about the
Russia investigation we can trust James
commis assertions that are good for
Trump from that meeting but not the same
assertions from the same meeting that
happened to not be good for Donald Trump
we suspected that Donald Trump would be
live-tweeting the James Comey testimony
he didn't actually tweet until the day
after right but he was able to wrap up
that cognitive dissonance all in one
tweet together stunning fascinating
absolutely fascinating and by the way
this whole Trump is 100% willing to
testify he was 100% willing to release
his tax returns as soon as XYZ happened
we're not getting those Pat I don't
expect that we're going to see Trump
testify under oath no I mean a sitting
president has only testified to Congress
while they were in office of course
three times hasn't happened since Gerald
Ford when he talked about his decision
to pardoned Richard Nixon is that right
I think under you know those
circumstances he's not going to go along
with it all right I did not know that it
had happened uh you know any of the
other of the three times where have
Abraham Lincoln in Woodrow Wilson Wow
yeah so yeah not likely to happen but
hey at the same time lots of things are
happening under Trump that no one would
have guessed were likely to happen